hey there my name is cameron and you are
watching motion science and in this
lesson we're going to talk about balance
and i'm going to start with two simple
examples here we're going to talk about
symmetrical balance and asymmetrical
balance
so what i have here in this first
composition is six circles and
symmetrical balance says that
these six circles can be arranged
in a symmetrical way okay
so there's a lot of different ways we
can do that one way we can do that is we
can
select these three down here we can
bring
these guys up here and symmetrically
balance them right we don't want to
scale them but we could select we can
use a line
uh to help us so we could select like
maybe these three bottom ones and we
could say we want them to be aligned
vertically and you see how they snapped
into place there same with these three
so i'll do a little bit more different
i'll align them uh drastically different
right here and then what we'll do is
we'll say the same thing let's align
them vertically and boom they're aligned
vertically
and then we can also do things like we
can select these two we can align them
horizontally
same thing align horizontally
same thing align horizontally
so we've got those we could
um
we don't want to do that because it
brings them all together but we could
distribute layers
so here we have them
we could bring them closer together like
this and you can see
now if i hit
my keys here and bring these in the
center we've got
asymmetrical balance right we could also
select all of them like this
and
we could
rotate them all
so
we could make it you know balanced
vertically
instead of horizontally so maybe
something like
this
and again i'm just gonna arrange
[Music]
them something like that
and there's different scripts out there
that you can actually use to take
all these layers together and
get them to all kind of
line up as one
unit showing a very simple way here but
there you've got balance
uh symmetrical so this says that these
circles are balanced inside of this
composition in a symmetrical way okay we
also have asymmetrical and what does
that mean well let's say we have
different sizes so like these two guys
here these are the same size this is a
big guy and this is a medium okay so how
do we balance these well there's
different ways you can balance them you
could
theoretically align this
to the center
you could bring this guy down here
you know
maybe like these guys here
and
then we've got we have a composition
it's still even though these are
different shapes
they're actually different sizes they're
still it's still balanced right this
this image still looks very pleasing the
eye versus having something like this
over here
this here this here right it's just that
is not so
asymmetrically balanced this balance is
something that i've learned
is something that takes time and it's
the more that you work with design
assets and
and
play around with
elements the better you're gonna get at
it
um it just takes time
so maybe something like this
you know maybe
bring this guy back up here and this guy
here looks a little bit better
doesn't have to be perfect
but you get the idea this is using
asymmetrical is using different sizes
of objects but still balancing them in
the frame
and
symmetrical
basically means they're all aligned
evenly
so with that in mind let's move on to
the actual design process so let me open
that project up
so here's our design
composition and there's nothing here yet
because what we're going to do is we're
going to work with all of these assets
right here
there's arrow layers there's three
arrows there's one
one two three four five 6 7 8 9 10
assets and the trick here is to get
these assets to
be balanced in this composition right so
our composition here is 1920 by 1080
it's just a standard hd
1080p 24 frames per second
composition and we're not gonna animate
anything here so five seconds is fine uh
we're gonna start with a solid though so
let's do a new solid
and
let's bring this up in here
something in that so pale red solid 2
that's going to be our background
and actually we need that solid layer
solid settings to be the same size our
composition just to keep it tidy
okay there we go next we're going to
bring in a texture
and there's our texture
and
let's play around
these transfer modes
not loving any of these so far
cycle back through to the top
that's not bad
something like this and we're going to
keep an eye on
whenever we're using balance we also
need to look at like these textures
right so this texture has
these splotches here they're lighter
here they're darker here we also have
like these creases in the paper here so
that's going to play into our balance so
we need to be aware of that so something
to keep in mind
uh next we're going to actually create
an asset here and
actually let's go ahead and bring in
our logo adidas logo
um we want to go ahead and shrink this
guy down it's too big
say this all the time with motion
designers where we're playing around
with assets
and
type is too big logos are too big you
know a lot of times we'll see something
like this
and
uh hit s for scale and it's huge right
it's filling the frame
for some cases this can work but a lot
of times we want it to be you know a lot
smaller
so
maybe
i don't know let's just place this guy
up in here
and if i'm not sure where to put
something
to start a lot of times i'm going to
turn on proportional grid i've got my
three by three set up
again if you don't know how to do that
preferences
uh grids and guides
once that loads up you're going to make
sure that proportional grid horizontal
is three verticals three click okay and
now you've got your
rule of thirds
three across and three down
so
our view what what what theory teaches
us is that this point right here is
always
the first point we're gonna look at this
is the second
third
fourth
and then these boxes can make up
additional points so let's go to our
first point which is going to be here
and i want to create a design asset
that's not up here
that replicates these bars
so to do that let's make sure nothing is
selected here
let's go up to
a rectangle box here double click
and we have made
a shape layer that's going to become a
rectangle so
we want to
fill this in let's make it white
actually let's just make it a red color
for now
let's turn off the stroke
and then we want to make it a true
rectangle
so
we're actually going to make it kind of
more vertical
so let's do something like
this
let's go up
let's take it back up
let's actually go
1500 by
300
so there we go and we're going to rotate
it under transform rectangle we're going
to rotate it
60 degrees
and i'm just kind of replicating what's
going on up here it doesn't have to be
perfect like i said but that's pretty
close and you can see if we line it up
here
that's really close
so
next we're going to do is we need three
of them right because there's three
going across here because i thought it'd
be cool to use this as a shape the shape
layer kind of playing off of these three
shapes
so
let's add a repeater
and repeater needs to be three copies
and we're to move it across
if i can see it
where are you at
not sure why i'm not seeing that so
let's do it again
repeater we go
that was kind of weird
uh three copies and let's transform it
and let's move them across
something like
that 430 pixels
so we'll call this um rectangles
and
i didn't want to grab that let's go
ahead and lock that
rectangles uh
let's lock that background as well
that's the thing with repeating when you
use a repeater i can only select the
main shape layer i can't select these
two guys here so that's why i kept
trying to do it kept starting to select
those
so i have to select this guy
so again i'm looking to place this
somewhere that's kind of you know it
could be front and center here that may
work it may not so we're going to scoot
it over here to the side
and
what else do we have here we have the
main
focus which is our shoe okay
and the shoe sometimes we get assets
that aren't you know super great
this is one of them look at this
bottom shadow here right now i could go
into photoshop this is the time i would
use photoshop and i could go in here and
i could clean this up i could paint it
out
feather it a lot i could use a mask here
in after effects um i'd probably use
photoshop
and kind of paint out the edge
but uh we can get away with not painting
it out
and that is by using a transfer mode
transfer modes are my favorite thing to
use
uh that obviously doesn't work
but we can try one that does
so let's try my other favorite which is
typically multiply or darken
and
that's looking okay that actually helps
this kind of blends in a little bit
better let's try darken
uh that looks pretty good too i actually
like that little bit better as far as
multiply
it also try color burn that's nice i
like that a lot so
it's going to be between dark in
and
color burn
and let's go with color burn
let's do that so
looking at this adidas logo if this is
where it's placed i don't want my shoe
to be so large number one so let's scale
this guy down
maybe something like that
and
[Music]
using balance principles
it's nice to see a logo here and then
you know contrasted to the opposite
angle opposite corner is the shoe
so we could try and maybe place the shoe
over in here
yeah something like that
now the stripes not bad
right where it is here
but something else i want to use
is some of these arrows right so if i
bring an arrow in here
if i start pointing out
different parts of the shoe because
let's pretend this is a it's an ad for
ultra boost right this it's all about
this shoe
and maybe we want to focus in
on the word ultra boost
so
we need to see there's a lot going on
here right now with these red lines
so it's something to keep in mind
we also have this arrow
you know maybe it's pointing to ultra
boost or maybe it's pointing
to the actual sole
and here
i kind of like it there
and
[Music]
this guy what is this one so we have
another arrow here
uh and we can always rotate these so r
for rotation
and click and drag and
you know maybe this one's pointing
upwards
at
this
or something and maybe it's scaled down
slightly
uh if we had a creative brief or
something like that it may be more
specific about how we have to use arrows
and things like that
but um
yeah i mean that's a lot going on so we
need to fix this but let's continue with
we've used 10
204 so this is what is this
this is different objects
um that would be interesting to use so
we have these guys we also have a
protractor here which is this guy
so
we need to really start balancing things
out
to make this work
and i need to decide what i want to use
from this
it would be nice to have this straight
ruler here
uh to contrast this protractor here so
let's pick
this
ruler here
and i'm just going to select all of it
including the shadow below it there
and
we're going to
maybe scale this up a bit
maybe in here
uh and we could use it you know because
it's long like this we can rotate it
over here on the side
we could leave it flat like this you can
see how i'm rotating it it's
rotating off this anchor point so i'm
going to undo that
window animation inc
anchor point mover from animation
composer i'm going to center it up right
there
great
okay so now if i rotate it
again it's going to kind of stay in
place
so i'm wondering if we push something
over in here
or something here
or if we zero it out and
maybe we go
somewhere in here like we're measuring
the shoe
that could be kind of cool
something like that
let's try
some different
that makes it really disappear
that's not bad at all i like that
uh now the shoe let's lock the
protractor the shoe
is gonna need to come up some
you know maybe something like that
this arrow down here is really competing
with this ruler
so we're probably going to want to take
that arrow
and
move it out of here
maybe it's up here and it's pointing
downwards so it's
pointing here
and looking at this the protractor
again it's really heavy on this side
over here
but i like the measurement tools being
associated with the shoe because we're
really talking about the shoe here so
let's actually get rid of these
rectangles let's bring these over here
now i do want to see the three of them
because if i only see two
this i mean i get the same idea that
this is something to do with the adidas
logo but it doesn't really
say a whole lot without seeing the three
now that does not mean i have to see all
the three right i could just see
part of the three so like this maybe
something like that
i think the shoe has got to scoot over a
little bit more
as well
now it's okay if he kind of crosses over
onto this
that's kind of interesting
uh now with the pro with the ruler i'm
going to scoot it back because remember
we're pretending like we're measuring
the shoe
so let's just line it up there
drop it down maybe like that
then we've got our protractor here
let's rotate this guy
something like this
yeah it'll work scale 100 sure
and let's bring him up here and let's
try darken as well
yeah like that
that's cool now you can see here on this
texture layer texture layer 10 to turn
it off
well number one you can see what a
difference it's making in the
composition but number two is look at
these lines that are up in this section
here if i turn it on
see these lines are a little bit
distracting so it's something again i
want to be aware of with my composition
and the balance so i'm going to bring
these guys over here
so a little less noticeable but we still
have some that really nice texture up in
here
looks really nice uh again let's
see about
the red here
i'm gonna make a little bit darker
mm-hmm
and
you know maybe this logo
needs to kind of push up in here
let's
play with this a little bit more zero
let's see here
let's bring down the brightness
maybe something like that let's make
sure adidas is on top
and
we'll bring it down kind of sits in in
this nice little window right here
and let's bring in a texture and texture
number three
this looks pretty nice
um we're going to alpha matte the adidas
logo
above there
and we're also going to let's try invert
channel invert
yeah so we've got
now in just instead of just a flat logo
we've got a textured logo and i could
probably scale this down
and find an interesting like that's kind
of nice right in there
but i could also play around with it a
little bit more here
oh that's nice too very subtle
right but it's got some interesting
texture there
let's also bring these guys over just a
bit
maybe so it crosses through the logo
here
yeah i like that
so we're going to actually
bring this these letters these
shapes over um and we're gonna align
like this see that looks a little bit
better
um before we had like this and i liked
the
red
rectangle like cutting through the logo
at the top here but i didn't like the s
hanging on by itself
so just bringing it over like this and
kind of centering up adidas looking at
the width here looking at the width here
uh that works a lot better i like that
i'm also going to lock that protractor
grab this little guy here
and
i'm going to line i'm going to rotate
so that it kind of lines up with that
rectangle as
well and maybe bring it over here
and shrink it down
[Music]
and kind of just go like that sure okay
what else we have here let's rotate
let's actually scale
so we're going to negative scale 100 so
we flip it
yeah like that
and we're going to put some emphasis on
this guy so r for
[Music]
rotation something
along these lines and let's bring this
guy down here
and we'll put some type up here it just
says like ultra boost so we'll type in
uh oh
uh let's see is that two it's two words
boost
and looking at this type it doesn't work
right it's because it's so modern this
is den light
but i think i had one
in here that i downloaded from somewhere
rini beanie that's it
and it just has like a nice
kind of written feel to it
so i'm going to
increase the size of this guy
maybe about 100
and bring it here
and then i'm just going to
make it black
and looking at this it looks okay but
it's now it's competing with the adidas
logo right look across here so this is
point number one we're looking at and
then point number two but they're too
close to the same size
so we actually should probably just
shrink this guy down
and
[Music]
you know maybe something like this now
the arrow
so let's rotate that arrow let's rotate
it some more
maybe let's scale it down
maybe take both of these and move them
down in here yeah
i like how ultra is kind of playing off
the the tip here
of the shoe
so again let's maybe rotate this guy
even more so rf rotation
and
maybe like that
yeah that's not too bad
and what else we have here we also have
so i want to bring in some more texture
here so we've used that this is it the
paper let's bring in the paper
and let's bring this guy down here
and for this i'm thinking darken again
or
[Music]
multiply
maybe multiply
let's turn off our proportional grid
and i don't know that's it's really
interesting it it feels though maybe
like it's too much right so darken
is there but darken doesn't feel like
it's enough so let's go back to multiply
maybe try color burn color burn's kind
of in the middle there so maybe we'll go
with color burn
maybe not let's bring in one more
texture here
and let's drop it in as well
and let's set this guy to screen
and you can see on this texture it
brings in like these white specks here
which are really nice as well
and we can just position you know as we
see fit wherever we want to see these
white specks so we've got some nice
contrast here um with the black versus
the white and the red this is a lot of
contrast happening here we also have
some contrast with the foot here
and i know this isn't a lesson about
contrast but i just wanted to point that
out to you
uh also we've got some really nice
balance it's i mean that's what we're
trying to accomplish here it's balance
right and it's it's looking really nice
so a couple more things i want to do
here to kind of finish this piece out is
this guy
i don't love i didn't love how he's
positioned here just want to cut them
off a little bit more maybe scale them
up a little bit
all right something like that
just give it some balance now there's a
lot of negative space here which that's
okay
but i'm wondering if
the
type needs to be up back up in this area
so we're gonna do is we're gonna
duplicate command d to duplicate and i'm
gonna
turn off my original text and lock it
and i'm doing that so that if i want to
go back to this i can easily just go
right back to it and come back up here
and let's increase
the size again something like
100
and again with the arrow i liked the
this arrow as well so i'm gonna
duplicate that one go to the bottom turn
it off keep it there so it's there
good to go as well
and actually i want to
bring this guy up here
and lock that guy so those are the two
so for this guy let's bring him up here
with this ultra boost and let's scale
this guy
back up
and kind of see
because that's nice too
right i just i'm not totally sold on the
adidas logo
with the type here but i think it does
work
i'm going to go ahead and select
everything and i'm going to close these
down so i can kind of see what's going
on so these are my two saved layers if i
want to go back to that look
uh and then to finish this piece before
i let me save it here really quick
i want to apply it like an overall
color look so we're going to go to layer
new adjustment layer
and we're going to call this
color grade
and to this we're going to apply effect
color correction
lumetri color
and here in basic color correction we
are going to
create a custom
input lut and this is from the preset
pack that you're going to find here
in motion science and i'm going to
browse to that
and here are the retro luts that are
included in the motion science
membership i'm just going to select um
start with number one and just see
they're really fun to use these luts i
mean you can see look at that you know
it's really awesome really kind of
changes the look of this
uh let's try another one let's try
number two
[Music]
i like that a lot
that's really cool so i'm gonna go ahead
and
duplicate i'm gonna save this one turn
it off duplicate
i'm gonna go browse again
number three
uh that's pretty cool as well like that
duplicate
and let's browse this one let's go
number four
wow that one's really nice too
so many great ones to choose from so
let's duplicate one more time and let's
try number five here
and there you go number five
um that's too contrasty i mean it's
really interesting but it's a little bit
too contrasty for me
uh i think i can always come back
so
there's one
i like to also sometimes combine them
and i that's probably like a rule that
you're not supposed to break
but i like to break it
so one looks really great so one
and that one's kind of nice
so that looks pretty cool so you know
what we're gonna go the one thing i just
want to do is i want to bring a little
bit more contrast into the red here
to really balance it out because it's
nice
what's nice about this bottom lut is
that it brings in a lot of contrast here
right
so let's go with number one
but to the red let's just go in and
let's just make it darker
maybe something like that
and back to the top we'll take a
screenshot
that's pretty nice compare
uh let's actually go back to the first
one here and let's just try one thing
here with the
uh with the
paper that we brought in let's
try multiply
again i like all the lines
up in here but not here
so we'll go back to color burn
and just to bring a little bit of it
back in i could duplicate this layer
a little bit too much that i could drop
the opacity down
[Music]
at the top layer maybe like 40
and then i could do like a really rough
mask here around the shoe
just very rough
kind of like so and then just feather it
but we actually want to subtract from
this
i mean you can see how it brings a
little bit more detail in up in here
you know what i think i like it without
so we'll duplicate we'll delete that
duplicate
and i'm going to call it good so there
is our adidas
design style frame
using
balance in motion design
[Music]
you